this is us star Chrissy Metz is also
making music moves for her new movie
breakthrough and this is really cool
she also got to shoot her first ever
music video
Chrissy giving Michelle Turner some
exclusive behind-the-scenes school a
[Music]
couple takeaways cuz I saw a little bit
of the behind scenes first of all come
on extensions yeah yeah and then come
through Jesus walking on water West it
was a really cool set up and walk on the
water but it was a really cool effect
yeah nobody felt I was gonna say when
did you think in your head like if I
fall during this if I sleep well we had
one dress right so they were there with
no backup so I was like we can't
[Music]
it took just one day to shoot the pink
dress was custom and that water started
out ice-cold the 38 year old filmed the
music video for I'm standing with you
the theme for her faith based movie
breakthrough six weeks before she
debuted at the ACMs
alongside Carrie Underwood and company
can I show you a little support here
real quick oh no not a surprise folks
Crissy Metz is my heart it was so
awesome with all those women joining her
on stage because I know she was a little
nervous you can't help but be a little
nervous when you're having your live
singing debut but she killed it she
killed crushed destroyed so happy so
proud the woman can sing her booty off
that helps she can sang yeah surely we
know sterile in the city we know you
could sing we know man Dickinson right
Christians the Christian saying when we
go and get the musical there was
whispers about doing a live episode so I
know there's people who would love to
see a musical episode listen it's a very
you gotta be careful with that stuff
[Music]
[Applause]